be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so to the best of my knowledge we've
covered all of the omega-level mutant
however if there are some that I've
forgotten feel free to add them down in
the comments section of the video and
I'll take a look at it and make sure
that I'm all caught up like I need to be
but with that in mind what I want to do
here is transition to omega class
weapons beginning with the power cosmic
now for those of you who are unaware
while the term omega-level mutant is
designed to differentiate powerful
mutants from those with the capabilities
to wipe out earth or the universe itself
Omega class weapons are a little
different with omega-level mutant being
determined by the mutant community
themselves more specifically the x-men
weapons are usually assigned in Omega
classification by Earth's intelligence
organizations including shield the
supreme headquarters international
espionage law enforcement division sword
the sentient world observation and
response department strike the special
tactical response for international key
emergencies armor the alternate reality
monitoring and observational response
agency and canada's dept k as a result
and much like omega-level mutant x'
there are only a handful of weapons
which have received an omega
classification some of which only
appeared a handful of times and some of
which have heared a multitude of times
now regarding the power cosmic this
received its designation from sword and
originates with Galactus himself covered
in my series on a history of the mobile
universe prior to the events of seiga
wars Marvel's universe was the seventh
version with a sixth version housing
Galan while the events that led to the
sixth universes collapse are varied when
everything died that reality's version
of eternity merged with Galland who was
born with a new universe as Galactus
that said while Galactus did and
continued to possess massive amounts of
energy Marvel has never been clear-cut
on where the power cosmic comes from in
some cases it's been stated that the
power cosmic comes from the astral plane
a dimension within the multiverse
accessible only to psychics of
sufficient power and those who are
strong in the use of magic on the other
hand it's been argued that the power
cosmic is the fundamental energy of the
universe from which everything
originates the regardless is something
that I want to do here is differentiate
between the power cosmic
and the
Gauntlet where the power cosmic presents
itself as an energy allowing its wielder
to manipulate cosmic energies the power
cosmic itself is still a fundamental
energy of the universe to this end the
power cosmic falls under the control of
the Infinity Gauntlet reality gem
allowing its wielder to supersede
Galactus himself that said the power
cosmic is capable of virtually any feat
regardless of how that feat falls within
the confines of universal laws of
physics the best way to think about this
is with a cup of water if this cup of
water represented the universe according
to traditional laws of physics the water
cannot simply be made to vanish instead
it has to go somewhere
whether it's pouring the water on the
floor throwing it out the window or
drinking it likewise if a person dies
their body does not simply disappear it
decomposes becoming part of the soil on
earth however this is not the case with
a power cosmic and instead of being
confined by these laws its wielder can
achieve a litany of feats in addition to
this because Galactus wields the power
cosmic in its totality while it's been
speculated that the cosmic entities may
use this energy source as well the fact
that they largely remain inactive in
comparison to Galactus who routinely
consumes worlds there's no way to know
for sure
as a result whether by virtue of
creating heralds or by the necessity of
a particular situation Galactus has
bestowed a portion of the power cosmic
on particular individuals but only
providing them with enough to serve a
singular purpose as an example with
Silver Surfer being the most popular he
was abused with enough of the power
cosmic to achieve cosmic awareness
allowing him to instantly locate planets
for Galactus to consume as well as the
power necessary to defeat nearly any and
all enemies as a means to continue his
role as a herald on the other hand
another Herald named Gabriel and using
the moniker of air Walker was not on the
same level of Silver Surfer and instead
possess enough strength equivalent to
Ben Grimm of the Fantastic Four while
also equipped with a horn that allowed
him to summon Galactus from any location
now having said that the power cosmic is
effectively the universe incarnate and
as such can manipulate the universe
itself beginning with cosmic awareness
this is not the same as omniscience
where omniscience is the possession of
knowledge on all things that have ever
and are currently happening in the
universe cosmic awareness allows
Galactus to be aware of all things that
may affect him in some form or fashion
as an example during time runs out and
while in the middle of a conversation
with the Illuminati on how to end the
incursions Galactus alongside the
Celestials had simply just vanished now
what we know that this was due to the
beyonders engaging in a massive battle
with the cosmic entities from across the
multiverse Galactus cosmic awareness had
allowed him to recognize the fact that
the beyonders had entered that reality
and systematically begun destroying
every cosmic entity they found following
this Galactus is capable of using the
power cosmic to raise the dead create
force fields impenetrable by those but
the smartest or most powerful beings
bestow and strip powers from anyone
aside from those of equal power alter
the molecular structure of matter to
create destroy or restructure life
control and manipulate the souls of
others teleport any distance across the
universe manipulate and control the
minds of others adapt his appearance to
reflect whatever ray sees him absorb and
discharge energies capable of destroying
solar systems alter the size of himself
and others to unlimited levels both
large and small as well as immortality
allowing himself and Franklin Richards
to survive the beyonders and the
collapse of the multiverse into the
formation of battleworld and the rebirth
of the earth-616 universe that said is
something I want to do here is point out
the difference between power cosmic and
cosmic power while on the surface it
seems like a shifting of names in
reality the difference between these
ideas is huge during your travels in the
realm of marble comics you may have
heard concepts like the uni power or the
enigma force taking these in turn the
Enigma force is exactly as it sounds a
force of energy with no known origin
hailing from the Microverse the Enigma
force is actually a sentient energy and
exists to keep itself alive by any means
necessary however because the Microverse
is far simpler than the main Marvel
Universe the Enigma force is assumed to
be the source of the Microverse itself
to this end and at some point on the
line the Enigma force sent out an aspect
of itself called a uni power now because
the Microverse exists as a pocket
dimension of our universe the uni power
exists to keep our universe protected
against those foes who would try to
destroy it as such the unit power seeks
out and merges itself with a being
during a tunnel
Isis allowing that person to transform
into captain universe and channel the
universes various energies to achieve
their goal as a result while captain
universe is very powerful in comparison
to your typical earthbound hero on the
whole the uni power pales in comparison
to the abilities of Galactus that said
if you've seen my video on all-new
all-different Ultimates we had talked
about how the group exists for the
purpose of eliminating threats to the
universe regardless of where they hail
from to this end the team's first act
was to target Galactus as a devourer of
worlds believing that his actions were a
detriment to existence now something to
point out here is that the Ultimates did
not come to this conclusion arbitrarily
instead both Black Panther and Adam
Bashir had reasoned that Galactus was
actually incomplete and had originally
emerged from stasis prematurely
completing the transformation process
Galactus emerged as the life bringer
creating life on dying worlds as opposed
to destroying them now where Galactus
continues to possess the power cosmic
but uses it for an entirely new purpose
and while beings like the Beyonder are
currently absent as it stands at the
moment there are two beings who
surpassed the power cosmic in terms of
abilities with the all-new all-different
marvel universe
the first is Owen Reese and the second
is covered as a holdover from the pre
Secret Wars universe for those of you
guys who have not seen in my discussion
on his character Owen Reese possesses
the power to control the molecular
structure of matter regardless of where
that matter originates meaning he's
considered a multiversal threat in
addition to this because the power
cosmic is an actual energy source its
energy is composed of molecules meaning
Owen Reese effectively controls the
source of Galactus as energy conversely
in the pre secret Wars universe cosmic
cubes were considered a source of
contained energy allowing its wielder a
level of power they greatly exceeded the
power cosmic however as time progressed
the cubes would become sentient and
evolve into unique beings who contain
the totality of the cubes power that
said and all-new all-different marvel is
part of the lead-up to civil war to the
Avengers found themselves at odds with
shield who had begun the process of
securing cosmic cubes with the intention
of recreating reality based on their
perception of security measures as a
result the cube evolved in its own
fashion eventually transforming into a
girl named Kovac
who imbued the cubes full powers to
control virtually all facets of reality
itself up to and including the power
cosmic with that being said we're going
to go ahead and bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it and if
you guys are interested in seeing more
videos like this make sure you guys
subscribe be sure to hit the like button
and leave a comment down below and I
will catch you guys later peace
[Music]